hey guys what's up this is andrew for
censensus.com so in this video guys i'm
here to make an update on spy triple q
guys the global market because it's very
important to understand what is
happening there so that you can adapt
the strategies you have on the different
stocks so let's get into it
[Music]
okay guys so i've done a video on spy
and triple q i think last week
i was showing you the counting elliot
with counting since march 2020 all right
and i was telling you guys that we have
two different scenarios either
we have completed
one two three four five like that
and we are correcting in this situation
we would have a longer correction an abc
that might be lasting six months you
know something like this
so hope it's not like that and would
probably go to the
400 level of 380 okay so this is the
first scenario it's like very bearish
right
to go to 380 and spy it would mean from
here
a drop of 15
more okay this is the most bearish case
there is nothing more more bearish than
that in this situation because
i mean i don't have any more bearish
signals on the very long run but the
alternative scenario it's not the
alternative it's the preferred scenario
guys this is what i'm showing you for
quite some time this was alternative
scenario the very bearish one
mine
the one i think would happen is less
bearish okay so it's saying that we have
a false wave and then the fifth wave
would come to the 500 area something
like this uh during 2022 okay maybe
after june or something like this i
don't know maybe starting in may it's
hard to really say when it's going to
start we need to analyze what's going to
happen
and in this situation
it would be the same we would do an abc
i'm going to do triple q together so the
question we're having is
first we're moving down so first is the
a wave so it's a correction so it's
going to happen doing an abc whatever
happens so the uh difficult thing is to
know
where is the a wave before it's complete
where is the b wave and where is the c
wave all right yes this is what i'm
trying to do
so on triple q it's more i would say
sorry let me get rid of that but
it's more obvious okay
because we have
here one two three four five okay you
can see daily time frame
after breakout
we can draw
five waves down okay
so this is telling me that the a wave
might be complete because i have five
waves all right whereas when i check on
the spy
it's difficult to see five waves here
i can do five waves but i i need to
really like a bit
uh overdraw the force wave alright i
don't really have this false wave here
so i struggle to find five waves in my a
wave okay i can also do do a small one
two higher but it doesn't look very good
because the second wave would be above
the top of the first wave so it's not
respecting elliot wave rule so i i
struggled to find a really good counting
for my a wave but i believe the best one
is this one
okay with a small force wave here so i
think the a wave is complete so if the
airwave is complete you should be in a b
wave all right guys so how long would
the b wave last it's hard to answer that
question i already told you how high it
can go and we reached that level all
right i use fibs and i told you 460 it
went to 4
58.
okay
so just a lit and the fib is that 459
all right so it's very close to the 61.8
percent of fib retracement
so i personally took a short position at
this level on triple q but whatever so
right now are we in the c wave maybe
okay it's hard to say but
let's check triple q triple q is giving
us i think a good hint about
the fact look i put volume here right
because the volume is very important
guys okay once again we are here trying
to understand to analyze a breakout
situation we are wondering if a breakout
above this trend line
and above the streamline would be a good
and reliable breakout and would be maybe
the start of a new move up or if it
would be a typical b wave fake out okay
b waves guys they're very tricky you
always think at the end of the b wave
that the market is strong enough and
actually that there will not be any sea
wave okay this is what i
got from my experience guys is that b
waves trick you so now and i got tricked
so many times by b waves guys so i know
that
this trick is not yet here but when i'm
gonna see it i'm really gonna feel this
is a trick
so to know if it's a trick we're gonna
analyze if it's a good and reliable
breakout and by the way guys uh i'm
building a course about breakout it's
been a few months i'm almost full time
on this it's going to be
very like precious information that i'm
going to give you guys a full
step-by-step method to actually use
volume volatility and momentum
in your trading and to be able to
identify good and reliable breakouts i'm
also gonna give you guys a full entry
method that's gonna help you to know
when it's time to get in when it's also
time to get out so i'm doing all of that
so if you guys are interested just click
on the link in the description of this
video it's my elliot wave landing page
uh but i'm gonna update that but at
least i have your email and i'm gonna be
able to send you information regarding
this course whenever it's gonna arrive
which is around two weeks guys and of
course you're gonna get a massive
discount because you deserve that guys
you've been here with me since the
beginning and i truly appreciate that
and that's also why i want to you know
try to give you the best material i can
uh if you want to improve your trading
so let's go back to what i was saying
here
is it the b wave or has the c wave
already started so to know that we check
triple q
and let's check the volume guys because
in the b wave volume is not back okay
and if the c wave would have started
the volume would increase on the
downside you know because
it would be brutal moves down and we had
a very brutal move down on triple q we
moved down by four percent guys because
of facebook that missed earnings and you
know the whole tech companies got
massively sold off
but look at the volume minus four
percent
this day on this on the third of
february guys and the volume was
actually lower than the volume we had
the week before when the moves were
minus two
and minus one percent all right so
basically we move with bigger moves but
involving less volume typical b wave
guys all right so this looks like
investors are not interested to trade uh
they don't sell they don't buy even if
when the market market is moving that
much i mean they trade less than they
used to so this is showing me guys that
we have balance okay despite the very
strong moves and it looks to me like a b
wave so is the b wave complete or not
it's hard to say i would say it's not
complete
because i don't have this fake out that
usually happens in a b wave so i'm
waiting for this breakout here to happen
and once again that's why guys the
course i'm building is going to be very
helpful here because i'm very sure we
won't have all
the information that we need to have for
good and reliable breakout which is a
consolidation that is
very tight and very close to the trend
line involving low volume for now this
is not the case
and we also need to have a strong volume
increase on the day of the breakout so
let's see guys i'm gonna monitor that
and if i see a breakout that is looking
weak
i'm gonna sell it all right and i'm
gonna play the c wave once again the
reason why i'm taking short position on
this market is because i have positions
on a lot of stocks and it's protecting
my position okay so this is my purpose
and then i'm gonna take profits if the
sea wave happens around 415 and i'm
going to reload guys by buying the dip
on many stocks around 400 or 5 which is
around 315 on triple q i hope this won't
happen but if it happens i will be there
to take advantage of this situation so
i'm think i'm done guys so what will
happen this week i'm neutral okay i'm
neutral i'm gonna check the breakout
above 455 for spy
which is above 360 365 on triple q if we
trade above 370 380 guys i'm gonna take
a short position here i'm gonna play the
b wave it will be the typical b wave if
we drop right away i have already some
short position so i'm happy with that i
will not increase it on the downside
because if it's a b wave we can have a
rebound coming anytime guys so i'm
neutral once again for this week but i'm
gonna monitor what's happening here and
if we break out below 440 on spy
which was the 200-day moving average
which was this resistance level we had
here
uh it would be the signal for me that we
might be in a c wave and the sooner we
complete the c wave the better so that
you know we are done with this
correction
and then we can see finally bulls uh
taking back control on stocks on crypto
on everything so i'm waiting for that by
the way we have a good bullish signal on
bitcoin so maybe this will go together
for now we are in a period of
uncertainty guys i'm personally keeping
very light positions i'm having
protection
and once things are looking great i'm
gonna be here to tell you
that to me it looks great and i'm
waiting for this moment so let's see
guys that's it for for today i hope you
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click on the sub like
and bell button so you're going to be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore see you guys